this Grandmaster walked away after
pre-moving Checkmate against Magnus
Carls on the first day of The Knockout
stage of the chessable Masters
Armageddon was where the action was at
three out of the four matches came down
to the wire and the only match that did
not go to Armageddon Wesley so made a
stellar comeback after being down one
game against levada Roni Hikaru Nakamura
refused to fall in an exciting match
against Vladimir fedesev and in a
hopeless position Hikaru did The
Impossible and discovered an
opportunistic stalemate idea better say
I saw this and it became a battle of
time the game was eventually drawn with
the 50 move rule giving hikara the
victory in a war between Fabiano caruana
and Lake Huang Lim all the match games
ended and draw in Armageddon Carolina
powered his way to Victory following one
critical mistake Magnus Carlson and
vladislavartinia traded wins back and
forth to go 2-2 before Armageddon after
a rare blunder Magnus lost his Queen the
only hope for Magnus was to win on time
vladislav would not allow it putting on
the pressure and winning in style that's
when